задача цих військових відбити позиції
які захопила ворожа диверсійна
група штурмова група вибиває диверсантів
з окопів двох беруть у
полонй
передаю наша група закріпилась
опостерігає ведем спостереження приняв
прийом наша група закріпилась держить
оборону це навчання протидиверсійних
резервів Вони працюють на північному
кордоні України військові фіксують тут
до десятка спроб проникнення російських
дрг
щомісяця змінилося те що їх присилають
сюди з інших регіонів Російської
Федерації присилають спеціально навчані
найкраще підготовлені це підрозділи
гругш РФ це підрозділи армійського
комплекту сил спеціальних операцій це
люди які заходять зі спеціальною зброєю
зі спеціальною підготов
люди які хочуть робити зло на
українській території цілі дрг і
військові і цивільні якщо Їм вдається
проникнути непоміченими Диверсанти
можуть працювати на території
супротивника по кілька діб замінування
кордону не гарантує цілковитого захисту
у складі дрг зазвичай діють сапери до
того ж ЗСУ не можуть мінувати всесе
підряд протипіхотні міни Україна
підписала міжнароднуже конвенцію Вони
мають бути тільки у керованому варіанті
Російська Федерація не підписувала такої
міжнародної конвенції вони можуть
розкидати вздовж усього державного
кордону А ми можемо тільки там де є
відповідно за цим спостереженням
російські дрг діють здебільшого на
кордоні з сумщиною і чернігівщиною а
також на Харківщині на півночі зручніша
для них місцевість багато лісів з
білоруського боку тихо помічати не
очевид Видне і самим бути непомітними
цьому навчають тих хто працює проти дрг
тут дуже велика специфіка цього Терпіння
навченість і адаптивність оце ключові
фактори які грають в саму ролю хоча
новин з північного кордону небагато
ситуація тут напружена лише за останній
тиждень листопада російські Диверсанти
тричі намагалися потрапити на українську
територію дві спроби ЗСУ відбили ще один
прорив призвів до втрат Віталій
досвідчений боєць так описує відчуття на
цій невидимій війні постійна невідомість
і на позиціях і не на позиціях
переміщені між
позиціями вернувся назад там банально
відійшов від трошки від лінії одяг
випрати помитись побритись Ну я вже кажу
вам відверто як є
воновичаз звичайні такі банальні речі та
які в нас посадені
ее можть
зіснутися що це будуть Украйні розумієте
Через такі групи які
висилаються аби бути готовими до бою
будь-якої миті військові не перестають
тренуватися на сотнях кілометрів
порослого лісами кордону безпілотники
незамінні вони допомагають вчасно
помітити дрг оцінити сили противника
коригувати
артилерію Дмитро Який ще нещодавно
керував до під бахмутом Тепер як
інструктор навчає інших ну як мінімум
дрони можуть висіти І вести пряму
трансляцію лінії зіткнення це робиться
ротацією чи тобто
каруселькою два пілота Для прикладу один
піднімає Дрон повітря і знімає в нього
починає сідати батарея він своєму колезі
каже В мене сідає батарея підмини мене
також можна їх вражати fpv дронами які
можуть осколочно-фугасний заряд носити з
собою до 2 кг це дуже велика вага і
дерег будуть розлітатись ось один з
останніх прикладів за допомогою дрону
Камікадзе нацгвардійці знищили Моторний
човен російських диверсантів на
Херсонщині на півночі ж як запевняють у
командуванні об'єднаних сил в України
зосереджені такі ж сили як і у РФ і
діють ЗСУ дзеркально у нас державний
кордон украї
тут на території Сумської чернігівських
областей кількасот кілометрів вони
обирають ніч Вони вибирають туман Вони
вибирають сніг Вони вибирають аврак Вони
вибирають русли річок Це ж люди які
навчені проникати за будь-яких погодних
умов Я хочу сказати що ми не сидимо
склавши руки Ми теж ведемо активні дії
це війна ми робимо подіб речі українські
ж диверсії дістають значно далі один з
прикладів дії легіону Свобода Росії і
російського добровольчого корпусу вони
не раз заходили на територію РФ у
білгородській області такі прориви
відбуваються і досі але як кажуть у
легіоні їх рідже
висвітлюють також Наприкінці листопада
сталося два вибухи на залізниці в
бурятії за 6 000 км від українських
кордонів за не офіційними даними це
успішна спецоперація СБУ інформації
жодної щодо відновлення її роботи навіть
в російській ЗМІ нема вони просто
абсолютно замовчують цю тему Проблема
росіїце насправді її розміри і територій
є для неї великою проблемою по-друге є
доволі значний спротив і всередині Росії
і є багато небайдужих росіян які я так
розумію готові співпрацювати з нашими
спецслужбами які прекрасно розуміють
злочинність режиму Путіна збої в роботі
залізниці вибухи на об'єктах енергетики
і військових підприємствах усе це має не
лише психологічний ефект а й заважає РФ
ефективно воювати Звичайно що там десь
ходять легенди що це там виключно пла
але Враховуючи те що ці вибухи як
правило відбуваються в не зовнішньо а
внутрішньо і наносять чи малу шкоду
Тобто це також можна Я думаю що віднести
до ефективної роботи наших вже
диверсійно-розвідувальних груп дуже
важливий
насправді створення ефекту
симетричності показувати що в нас Ми
також маємо можливості і маємо операції
якими ми можемо діставати до вас в тилу
українські військові небагато говорять
про диверсійну і протидиверсійну
діяльність навіть навчання які показують
публічно лише невелика частка того чим
займаються спеціально підготовлені
підрозділи комплектування комтува груп
підготовка груп озброєння В кінцевому
рахунку це може зіграти на руку
противнику вони розуміють що якщо
працюють проти диверсійні групи вони
можуть працювати проти цих груп
позитивний досвід не завжди показується
бо поки війна після війни думаю будуть
писати книжки фільми знімати може
подивимося якщо
пощастить вчитися протидіяти ворожим дрг
для військових робота і життєва
необхідність адже супротивник так само
готується і тренується а поки триває
війна про спокій на кордонах не
йдеться